the first few of a planned 500 Asylum
Seekers arriving on Monday at their new
accommodation a barge off England's
South Coast the plan has attracted
controversy And Delay over safety
suitability and scale 500 men represent
a tiny fraction of the people awaiting
an asylum decision but the government
says it's a necessary first step in
stemming the numbers of people coming to
the UK in small boats because of the
crisis we have in the channel we have to
provide accommodation and we have to
stop spending six million pounds a night
of taxpayers money on hotels which to
some extent are luxurious what we need
is more basic accommodation to stop the
pull factor the Prime Minister has made
it clear he wants to reduce the backlogs
and we're doing that around 50 000
Asylum Seekers are currently in hotels
at a cost of nearly eight million
dollars a day when the barge arrived in
mid-july it was met with protests by
those who see it as inhumane and those
who don't want the men there the Asylum
Seekers are human beings they need to be
treated with decency courtesy and
respect that human beings are best cared
for in communities a barge is not the
way to treat human beings there are so
many problems with housing people in
these conditions that it just it just
doesn't bear thinking about having so
far failed to deport migrants to Rwanda
Rishi sunak's government is on a mission
to cut the number of small boats
arriving in the UK nearly 4 000 people
cross the channel in June the fact that
the Bibi Stockholm has 222 cabins but is
set to house 500 men could also be seen
as a deterrent they're not prison ships
um you're not locked up on board
um you are free to come and go what the
prime minister is saying is that he
needs to find a way of stopping the
boats and a new law has just been passed
which will enable him to stop people
claiming Asylum if they're coming from a
safe Third Country and to return them
more quickly I think there's a real
message here
um to uh would-be migrants and Asylum
Seekers not to fall into the hands of
the smuggling gangs the main opposition
labor party says it too would use barges
in the short term while criticizing the
government for creating the problem by
not processing Asylum claims more
quickly the Bibi Stockholm is set to
operate initially for 18 months which
would take it past the next general
election in which migration policy is
said to be front and center Harry
Fawcett Al Jazeera